the U.S has once again reached its debt limits
the White House said President Biden is willing
to meet with house Speaker Kevin McCarthy but
that raising the debt ceiling they say is a
nut a negotiation but an obligation the treasury
Department warns of dire consequences to Everyday
Americans and Global Financial markets should the
U.S default on its debts Christina raffini is in
Washington with the latest on this Christina good
morning good morning Jeff well we're back to the
debt ceiling again look as you mentioned the good
news is Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy said
in a tweet he would be willing to sit down with
President Biden take him up on his offer to try
to hammer out a deal but the clock is ticking
and America's credit rating is on the line
if we don't meet our national debt and renege in
the first time we have a Calamity that Calamity
could become Reality by June 5th according to
the treasury Department if lawmakers can't get a
deal together now the big debate let me be honest
with you is a fundamental disagreement on what we
should do to cut what what do we cut well it's
not just cutting what do you raise what taxes
do people pay House Republicans especially those
who demanded concessions to elect Kevin McCarthy's
speaker say they want spending cuts before they'll
agree to raise the debt limit the American people
are sick of it they want some responsibility used
when it comes to spending their hard-earned money
but the White House argues there shouldn't be
any negotiation Over America making good on
money it's already spent we think that Congress
should deal with this in a bipartisan fashion
as they have 78 times in the past the national
debt is now around 31.4 trillion dollars default
could compromise the treasury's abilities to
pay out Social Security or Medicare and have
other negative repercussions on the U.S
economy America must have never default
wanted to do that it never has and never will now
in 2011 the U.S saw its credit rating downgraded
for the first time over brinkmanship over the
debt limit now we're not there yet but the closer
we get to that June deadline it could be deja vu
all over again guys all right Christina thank you